let there be no confusion alfonso
ribeiro can dance like dance dance and
after a brilliant performance all his
performance really yes I did
he is the clear front-runner on ABC's
Dancing with stars right come on of
course he is and you see what he did
he's a total pro he danced
professionally as a kid and it's you
know it's almost unfair to the rest well
I agree you know I called him out on
this at his dancing rehearsal I'm
waiting to see some of your tap dancing
skills a lot of people know you of
course be in Carlson conference and but
there's things that people don't know
about you like well people from New York
remember people people from New York
remember tap dance kid and obviously you
know the older generation remember the
Pepsi commercial but like I was 12 30
almost 31 years ago got it
I'm sure you saw that well it's like
riding a bike right no no no with all
this rehearsing and dancing how are you
able to stay away from your baby now it
is tough I do get my time with them and
I look at you know most Americans go to
work everyday they get home at 6 o'clock
and then they get to spend time with
their kids so at the end of the day I'm
really just doing what everybody else
normally does when they have kids that's
what I have first interview with yeah
we're taking it back 30 years to the set
of silver spoons
the hours are maybe a little longer but
it's a lot easier it's not easier work
no seems like to my
you talk the same no one really what
would you tell that little guy right now
so hey man chill out and stop going into
clubs but at the end of the day my life
brought me right here right now so I'm
not complaining one more thing
Ulf also has dropped 15 pounds so far
but it would be more if he would just
stay away from the cupcakes why would
you call a brother out like that okay
meanwhile I want to show you something
real quick check this out this was all
Fonzo trying to teach NBA superstar
James Harden how to do the Carlton dance
oh no it looks like the beer got it the
beer did get in the way he cannot dance
I love it